let's bring in Mike Huckabee Fox News
contributor and former governor of
Arkansas former GOP presidential
candidate good morning to you good
morning I usually great to be great to
great to have you on so I'm sure you
just heard Jillian's report about the WH
o how do you think they should be held
accountable
well if Adam Schiff wants to investigate
something
here's his target I mean this is
legitimately something that needs to be
looked into instead of wasting his time
going after the president who has a few
things on his plate let Congress take a
look at what H WH o did what they did to
conspire with China to cover-up the
virus this thing is shut the whole world
economy down and somebody needs to be
held accountable China first the WH
o--'s second but I think the president's
right let's see about slashing their
funding he's also right to say let's
don't eliminate it because then you
don't have the right to demand the
investigation and I think the president
would be able to get a lot of other
countries to join with him in asking for
a full accountability yeah FDA
Commissioner Gottlieb said they need to
recognize Taiwan they played it for a
big role in this they did they're not
recognized on the bass to China
and he goes China did not show did not
share the strain information did not
make it handy made it hard to share it
and they couldn't even develop a
diagnostic test obviously meanwhile as
we look ahead with the mess that China
has given the world we talk about an
economy that shut down and how we plan
on opening it up
dr. pouchy was asked about that he says
it's not going to be an immediate wide
open up to open up the key and just open
up the door and we started up listen we
are hoping that at the end of the month
we could look around and say okay is
there any element here that we can
safely and cautiously start pulling back
on if so do it if not then just continue
to hunker down and that's what at least
from the standpoint of the public health
aspect that we look at all the decisions
are gonna have to be made at the level
of the president and the governor's
about what they are going to do with all
of the information they get
so governor do you want to comment on
that I just got a quick follow-up on
what else pouchy said well look I think
on one hand we listen to the health
experts these are the people that we try
to ask what are the worst case scenarios
best case scenarios but none of those
people have been elected I just want to
remind ourselves all of us something we
live in a democracy we live in a country
where we elect our leaders to make
decisions we do not relegate delegate
and give over those decisions to people
no matter how smart they are we don't
give them to people who haven't been
elected by We the People and ultimately
while I respect what they're telling us
and we need to listen carefully these
are decisions they're going to be made
by the president and by the 50 governors
of the states and they make them based
on what's best for their population and
balancing the health concerns with the
fact that right now we've got millions
of people out of work our economy is
tanked and it is really threatening the
Civil Liberties of a lot of people and
that is a concern to me that I don't
hear enough about is how we are
shredding the Constitution by telling
people such things as you can't sit in a
car by yourself you're gonna get
arrested
you can't drive up to a church in your
own vehicle and the closest contact you
have is with the police officer comes
tells you you can't do it there's some
stuff that ought to scare the daylights
out of us for the long-term future Brian
dr. FAC she also went on in a series of
questions with Jake Tapper he said look
no doubt about it if the president
listened to us and shut down the
government earlier more people this
wouldn't have been as bad or more people
would have been alive and then somebody
who do one of the women a woman that we
ran against Nancy Pelosi tweeted out
Anthony foul she in January and February
never said never said that we should
shut down the government in fact
publicly said that it's not going to hit
us as bad here as it is in China and the
president retweeted it it ended with
hashtag fire foul Qi do you believe that
there's friction building between the
two I'm sure there is look this this is
wearing on everybody's nerves is the
president going to fire foul she
probably not I mean needs
he's been basically loyal to the
president he has his own mind and that's
one of the reasons the president has him
around to give him advice but ultimately
it's the president who is the decider as
George W Bush once famously said and and
I think that's what we recognize the
president was elected to lead the
country he'll make the decisions but
Falchi did downplay the significance of
this in late January early February
let's remind ourselves it was the
president who shut down travel from
China based on concerns that folks from
China particularly in Wuhan we're going
to bring that to the US and the rest of
the world what would have happened had
he not shut down hundreds of thousands
of people coming from China when he did
could have been much worse much sooner